it's happening finally nine months
behind schedule
yeah but in time for your discussions
it's been nine months since we made this
promise
well since the game came out and over a
year since we started resident knievel
yeah all leading up to this game if
you're just joining us because I feel
like of all the games this will get the
most amount of new viewers because it
came out this year and because a game of
your stuff and DLC is releasing soon
relevant
yeah it's relevant this is resident
knievel mary did not play many Resident
Evil's before we started the series now
you played almost all of them - a few
whoa yeah I've been going through every
one of them with Mike as my guide and in
six and five my my co player yeah
this is the first time I'm watching
again along with all you people for the
first time well I'm gonna go over indie
game people sick week I could remember
if there is I can interest in a medic so
we're starting from here okay but yeah
we're playing through the whole game if
you start to feel uncomfortable take a
break if camera movement is bothering
you
turn camera wobble off okay
start game normal there's no heart it's
just easy or normal
it's either yeah okay it's like normal
maybe if when you beat it do you get you
get a madhouse difficulty madhouse which
is very fun actually but as you can
assume hard
we put subtitles on it's happening
first time playing are you a baby I just
wanted to send a quick hello and I love
you oh good news I'm gonna be coming
home soon yeah yeah I cannot wait to be
done with this babysitting job and come
home to my loving husband I miss you and
my loving husband oh I gotta get back to
work I love you Ethan I miss you so much
I'm sending tons of kisses bye baby [ __ ]
I love this game so much
he's you were right I did lie to you
I shouldn't have all I can say is that
if you get this stay away oh and don't
look through my recorded TiVo TV shows
my private Teva hard bought for is not
my recording the dog it's not over what
can I say it's Ethan yeah yeah no I'm
good I'm good
it's me dad she's alive
she's back I don't know look I don't
know how but she's back she's back
somehow and maybe it's a prank she wants
me to come and get her where is she dou
V dou V Louisiana three years I know I
know what if it is her I have to find
out what happened
that's me first res legal game in first
person oh yeah don't be on Rails game no
nobody counts that Umbrella Chronicles
and I Drive no I mean they've changed
perspectives before you know and that's
something kind of notable about the
series is that they went from you know
having a still camera to having a
third-person perspective and that was a
huge you know leap for the game yeah
well they said like the intention was
the intention if this game did well
which it did was to start there's the
original trilogy with fixed camera
angles and there's the three over the
shoulder game so especially this could
be the first of three first-person games
which would be awesome because I really
love this game cool you know this is the
first time in a while I'm excited to
start a new game since like resin before
in this that's exciting well that makes
me excited which is good because when we
were playing five five I started to like
kind of lose my I don't know I just kind
of started to lose my composure
I just stopped passion hearing so yes
that's the one drive
all right energy all right okay so it's
saying find me uh but I can't oh okay
sorry I'm just learning what I'm doing
so I'm in Dolby Louisiana you know
reading the swamp real [ __ ] of a
house not yet on the grounds
yeah I'm close there's a way over this
way though it came from there all right
I'll just go this way
I think it's going to lock this gate oh
my god you're tuned in boots Troy what
was that the wind
all right you're gonna want that van
here wonder what it goes on in there no
it's got up mm-hmm
power power cable in it scuse me
sewer Gators sneak into a Louisiana
ghost house well okay
join us oh is that a that's a tripod
we've seen many of those in our day so
was that maybe like a news crew or maybe
yeah here are you spooked yet not yet
but I would say it's eerie but
is that guy what God was a guy I'll act
like you didn't see him I didn't see any
he was just there he was in that muddy
pond I'll run and catch up with him
[Music]
got spooked yeah well I wasn't but the
birds made up noise it's not the same
smells like poop in here listen if you
[ __ ] your pants this early on into the
game you probably shouldn't play it no
it wasn't one of the ideas for the name
of this show to be like the brown where
your brown pants to make room for all
the new [ __ ] yeah I'm so excited
this was the journey that we decided to
share together so long ago if only I can
go back in time and a warrant younger
Mike well you would have forgotten by
now because it's been a year and you'd
get rid of those memories lost the plans
like a time machine
purse of course
oh is that my girlfriend someplace
called the Texas
aha
here's something worth do you want to
turn notifications off by any chance do
you think that will harm my experience
yeah I think so
I think they're thinking back there
probably a few times where you do
something intense and then that pops up
and kind of hold you out if that makes
sense yeah okay I'd say it's worth it so
we don't do worry about it next episode
and then I'll check this too just in
case you know sometimes you get little
bonuses and these things you know yeah
go back to the first game to when you
can inspect stuff okay so you'll need to
turn off notifications yeah sorry on the
PlayStation all right but nobody look
there's I don't think is anything
important here actually there's all
always important things know your
messages you're not online
I made sure we're not online so we're
good
boom just [ __ ] turn them all off
disabled I think that's it sweet I think
that's all sweet and we're back nobody
look now you know her name and my is it
it changes when I change my facebook
profile picture I think or something so
they're connected it's weird that's it
you can move it though that's pretty
high your Papa little Timothy died on
that swing I made it really dark and
because of the lights that we use to
like you know lighten the under part of
Mike's
token eyes it's hot the reflection is in
the TV concave so deep deep socks so
it's hard to see it is extremely dark
I'm a bit concerned with how dare you
tradition that I haven't been able to
sorry for those whose ears drums I just
popped thank God for this light actually
like in general I'm gonna have the game
play audio louder than it was in Reggio
six boy is this the demo did you what
the [ __ ] I [ __ ] turn those off did you
not apply it go back to it one more time
sorry sorry
[Music]
I don't want to just back circle disable
popups I'll playing video thanks this
time we're back yes did you play the
demo yes okay
this isn't okay okay I have the PAX pox
great oh it's letting me use an item but
I don't have any item yeah you can see
the credit card open that lock okay I
also chose the paper first yes I played
the demo because that was before we made
this wait can I try this again
I'll stop it what is it I don't know
what this is oh [ __ ] your silhouette on
the bottom right of a girl looks like
standing in the door yeah that is
ridiculous that doesn't look like
anything terrible photo that's a real
[ __ ] photo that's unhelpful what's for
dinner
[ __ ] damn right
it was like a little cockroach in there
looks like Indian food wrapped in a
newspaper that's not original no clean
wats setup bird I think that's Mia my
girlfriend
god I feel like I'm playing this too
slow but I'm getting in the zone when
you're done that's just a bunch of
maggots yeah looks like that frigate
itself is alive I still need someone
some idiot thought that was the trashcan
these guys are real dumb over 20 missing
in two years okay well no I already read
that all right
all right so I need I still need to open
a lot of [ __ ] here and have no opener
not doing super hot
if resident evil wouldn't taught me
anything it's that you don't just go
around pushing buttons you like decide
what it is to do and then you execute
pushing buttons gets people killed
you've learned well oh oh that's how you
save yeah okay cool do I need tapes no
not on this difficulty
really I believe man how's you do okay
so it's saving now and I got a tape but
I can't play it all right I'm gonna I'm
gonna not touch that for now okay
hold on to that carrot that's like oh
it's me hey oh hey I'm a good-looking
dude okay unhelpful there's not a lot
going on here didn't give me the option
to not do that
where's Chelsea yeah that makes me
uncomfortable it's like on the back it's
like aged 13 and you're like ah but not
me
oh god that's uncomfortable no nice try
game series has conditioned you makes me
proud man gel so right it's coming
together
looks like the owners I feel like I'm
learning here so there's a mama a Papa
that looks really scary I think that's a
boy and a little girl what a loving
doting
oh [ __ ] oh there's something on the wall
over there and then I can maybe play the
tape here as a noise he's back on the
wall oh there's the family again this is
my brother Horace okay so I need to put
a fuse there but I don't call back some
early residents may be a bishop plug -
should I put the tape in there I should
probably learned something
[Music]
alright the video crew June 1st 2017
that what I said yeah I wouldn't present
a as few months after that what did you
find this guy
give me a break Pete hey I only work
with professionals
speaking of which make sure the sound is
right this time I don't want to repeat
of Amarillo that was two [ __ ] years
ago
I don't do ADR that sounds like a piece
of works new guy oh okay sorry you're
playing just don't be surprised I added
speech I thought I was watching it
possibly you in that soy intro I love
this just like we always do just try to
say the show's name this time okay no
problem tonight on sewer Gators another
worthless [ __ ] [ __ ] happy ecstatic
you're dead
I hope the cameraman lives this is a
cool concept of me being the cameraman
because it makes me want to focus on
them because that was what a growing
every man would do let's go give me that
breaching charge you cut so why are we
in hell this time
do you ever prep what's the prep shitty
house this would be a fun job like ghost
hunter show not with that [ __ ]
no I was an anchor you know we can sub
Pete not anchor what's then nothing he
was pretty clear
yeah pretty loud too what's the story
Andre abandoned farmhouse missing family
foul play suspected the usual
there are three years get a shot of this
plants make a great cut away mm-hmm
where hillbilly Jonah's family go
missing not Hillbillies the baker's jack
and Marguerite Baker and they were quiet
not backward a lot of bad rumors about
their son Lucas oh no apparently no
photo in this one [ __ ] I know I should
have wore my good shoes it's cool I'm
like playing the same oh I'm playing the
same thing just to make a great backdrop
ah Dre what do you think I'm probably
missing it ah Dre Andre Andre Oh
Clancy you see where Andre went oh where
is he I'm [ __ ] believable it's the
last time I work with that guy
I mean producers they coming dope but a
good cameraman like you Clancy you stick
with me this guy sounds scared he does
real Weiner a true Weiner what the [ __ ]
was that did you hear that I did
she's gonna make a real good cut away
Audrey Audrey where are you man
[Music]
can't play the piano no cameraman is not
a pianist and there's no photos did you
see that whoa all right new deal we find
Andre and we go let me [ __ ] this show
wait why wouldn't you just leave because
they still have a producer there I mean
check out classic ass but it's no peers
Nivens but it'll do this is me the
camera man the greatest camera man in
the world
getting the best shots you first oh [ __ ]
need a nice hero shot of me coming down
the ladder
what do you see what is it oh no can I
go back up the stairs you can try is
that my producer I'll get a good shot oh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
Ethan's turn to go down there Jesus
okay okay let's let's not go down there
we don't have to right I'm feeling
frisky now oh you son of a [ __ ] all
right well can I just leave if this is
anything like the demo which it is very
much there was multiple ways to do the
demo but I only did the one way that I
did which is what we're about to do but
I know that there's other things you can
do like like like find that this thing
or something but I don't remember so I'm
just gonna do the only thing that I know
how to do but I don't
so I will say the demos change the fuse
used to be on a box where you're
crouching right now right wait isn't on
top of this box I don't know no yeah
they changed it issues a few things
since the demo that makes sense I mean
you don't want it to be the exact same
and no why would I do this
it's brighter than the tape which is
good so the guy was here I do like a
homage to uh Blair which ending with
Mike oh that's the pipe that was in his
[ __ ] head gross
this is a motorcycle alright
like that
like it so hard to see we have to fix
this reflection issue like I see you
better than I see this game I can see
Mike like in the reflection of the TV oh
[ __ ] off
turn one of these lights off it's just a
dead guy let's see what it looks like if
I turn the light off is that thick
cameraman Andre oh whoa what's all this
now it's spookier can you see better
Oh than the other light I think it might
be the other light we'll find out um
that's better
um I don't think you'll be able to see
look better
yeah do you think we're still bright
enough to the people yes my eye sockets
are deep still but no not all looks much
better to me
not all of God's light can fix your deep
sockets Mike some garbage you guys have
been busy
[Music]
what what what's that does that mean did
I do that I actually don't know sorry
daddy
no I'm so sorry daddy
sorry daddy syringes
Oh God the game saved what like you
don't know when the game saves it means
you can totally die yeah okay I didn't
get anything for that yet yeah I also
think it's ironic or like it's just good
Burbage that it says that won't cut it
like it won't cut the chain but it's
also that it won't cut it cuz of this
[ __ ] good oh this is interesting
whose name is at the bottom and the two
names at the bottom three names at the
bottom actually Peter Andre and Clancy
what's Clancy is Elle what does that
mean don't know lost wait what was my
girlfriend's name Mia she's not on here
she's in the room right behind you
though turned wonder what that means
nice nose will cut it should I keep
going I should I should have three my
girlfriend I'm gonna save her oh she
does not look love what you've done with
this place thank God I found you it's me
it's season season are you all right you
shouldn't be here
what do you mean you contacted me no no
I wouldn't
did I didn't II went to see you did he
see you
who else is here what the hell's going
on daddy's coming we need to go we need
to go now she works she's one of the
little girl she's a little girl where
are you taking me someplace safe are you
gonna tell me what's going on
is this baby you've been gone three
years three years has it really been
three years is this one of those things
where she like hooks men and then
trapped them and then kills them with
her sexiness
what what is this place
what they do you not now we need to get
out of here first I think it's this way
I'll follow you
[Music]
what is all that is that meat bird oh
yeah sex yeah we have to talk message
you said not me
now it wasn't me but you did I didn't
okay fine just tell me what's going on
I'm telling you everything that I know
we have to go this way
I feel like she's not telling me
everything because she knows where to go
I bet you she knows something about
those meat sacks dude yeah
are you sure you know where you're going
family used to bring me food through
here I remember oh
there it's there
this is it hmm
I remember this room there's another
door here I'm sure of it and I shut this
it's gone it's gone
e we're gonna be a family now that
you're here he's yours everyone there's
another door I'm sure of it
she's [ __ ] losing it
[Music]
don't you worry girlfriend I'm gonna get
us out of here
Mia I gotta get out of here just stay
here all right I'm gonna have a look
around
I mean she's turning wait that's where I
came from and then there's this place
this green thing that looks like her my
girlfriend
wait behind you uh.thanks guide did it
sucker see the doors I miss it I feel
like I don't have any items can I don't
I don't think I have anything
Oh Lord
it's raining
why did they make me open the 9-1-1
dad
quick I'm gonna dial nine and one and
when you open the door I'm gonna tie on
one again what
it's The Simpsons but it's not quote
Oh a map that's nice
okay so coming up on my left is the
bathroom
Oh Lord
these tiles need some grout is I didn't
even read that first-aid med ok so I'm
getting some Occupato nothing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's locked
stupid Oh God
No
about me can I turn around or try sleeve
bought the door turn the door shut
it's so [ __ ] slow I hate that no no
no no no no no yeah you're drunk
I'm trying to reset
[Applause]
[ __ ] I'm dead oh no I'm just [ __ ] up
what is your problem
I can feel her inside whoa easy Mia
all right I'm [ __ ] up are you Mia
tequila will getcha she the gremlin came
out that's what happened to you and I
don't drink when I drank before if I
don't eat dinner
the gremlin comes out all right
sharpen would kill her dad anything I
did never leave sorry sweetie what did
we say about that stapler I feel so bad
about that
oh no she's still her
I feel like I could use that axe that's
the boys
the drawers with empty stuff is so mean
there anything else I can use that phone
was not working before so just find that
pretty rude I'm going on right okay
don't you get a bit of a
[Music]
what was that demo salad hills RPG yeah
the PT demo from here well who's this
then what the [ __ ] is going on yeah oh
there now
[Music]
this
No
okay
and you're back here alright the Attic
is up here right
it is typically attics are up shut up
attic attic is Latin for upstairs oh
right is it my shadow yeah sorry
jeez if I can't keep it together oh okay
sorry
okay wait all right so I need the fuse I
need to be all fun look around more up
here first all right now you could save
you I'm having some goldfish that's fine
I even I'm scared it's a trigger yes all
over right that save data or is this the
kind of game where you want to save data
in case you got to go back yeah yeah it
is that kind of more than two I wouldn't
never overwrite it really who's that
I hate stairs you see them
you need to fuse probably looking for
I think I need this fuse yeah but I've
been everywhere in this house and I'm
really good at no you got the bolt
cutters now oh yeah you're right okay
good idea
it's almost like I've played this before
your attention to detail is second to
just a few people can I get in here
that's [ __ ] I feel like those should
do everything now see ya
all right cool we've done some things I
would like to
I should probably go cuz like it'd be
cool to watch that do you see that no
you didn't see that person walk across
that door shut up
not kidding just ran scared okay
get your goldfish
Oh God how do I open that damn drawer I
remember when this demo came out -
everyone was like there's three ways you
can do it one is the drawer yeah this is
a different though [ __ ] off
okay the TV I think behind you is on
that too I was always on no no sorry
yeah you're right in your life I know
you didn't mean to hurt what's behind
your back I've done I [ __ ] knew I
should have kept that ax [ __ ] I need
another bottle oh my god hey hey hold
the screwdriver oh I'm pushing every
button my god I only got so many you
know
my good head I'm gonna need so many jars
go get your hand please oh I'll connect
that later I'm very likely to die
can you is your hand up here in your
head start yeah wanna look at it do you
like it yeah kind of hot press r1 when
you back out
I ate both my bottles cuz I didn't know
that I was thinking my hand cut off also
what would that have done
would it have connected my hand back at
the point
what was that bullet again
oh okay so I think okay fine okay so I
have a bottle now should I use it no cuz
like I don't have red stuff on my screen
[ __ ] yeah
you've lost your arms in battle you grew
some nice boobs though
yeah that's the second Robin Hood Men in
Tights reference in like Resident Evil
last episode of Robin Lincoln what are
you doing waiting guessing I guess no
one's coming did you say Lincoln said
hey Blake
it's better than not going in here but
okay what's going on all right can I
just leave again
oh those mannequins okay good I thought
they'd be staring at me when I came out
what game was that the darkness think
those things suck I hate them
something that table behind I know there
is [ __ ] act like I didn't see them
those things scare the [ __ ] out of me I
think there's a ladder also back here
near the light
now stuck behind you no no stop I'm not
gonna be behind you oh yeah right there
can you climb up there yeah yeah
wait what's having a
[Music]
please run and heal
where my going yeah through that do that
running it's hard
Oh the stairs are up baka reload Oh God
let me get a goldfish for this yeah
we're going here
why dad I didn't know that I forgot what
helped me it appears she can't use doors
the other way just go through the wall
where am I going
yeah yeah this way
um can I get up there
I like don't know what to do shoot her
in the face
why did shoot her more [ __ ]
here's me up can I kill her proper your
best bet oh yeah how do I reload my
stump
no it's counter can I take that from her
I'd like to take this
oh man I'm like so close to death here
let's get the [ __ ] out of here
Wow everything's [ __ ] up
that was daddy
[Music]
it's taking you to the big house
I'm almost out of hands come on don't
you die on us now you have work to do
I'm well I'm dead I haven't seen a menu
yet yeah I remember this from that what
the hell oh who are you people
where's Mia
[Music]
[Applause]
where are these daddy
you're in control right now oh I forgot
about her oh man I'm all [ __ ] up hey
g-man sometimes people call them Nana or
two - oh no she or me piss she's alive
Amy Pez yeah she's there she's still got
it oh hey Nico that's such a weird thing
to have me read no one made you read it
you know do I have both of my hands
because it would really let me look at
my hands yeah I'm burning when he was
strapping him in here had your hand back
on okay
need gun
Oh film crew oh yeah
gun [ __ ] they got me again what is that
pendulum or a lack of thereof on a
grandfather clock okay I don't think I
can use bullets on it toaster hardly
know her female fee 50s
meaty saute gross I don't even know what
I was reading
I think I must have been up here male
20s portly barbecue man they really like
meat so just we're just eating humans Oh
must find fun
goddamnit they got me again Chyna it's
nice - okay that's where you fall
all right some Doc Martin loves Martin
Amaro smart ducky Martos wait why do I
have the ability to pick this up just
for immersion yep there it is
Evaline down back there
actually not airman okay just thought
I'd try can I just
[Music]
I must have missed something
putting that grandfather clock or some
[ __ ] maybe I'm supposed to leave a
different way I wonder if this is like
the demo where I can actually do it in
various ways oh I don't even want to
leave though because I feel like that's
how you die
what should I do
well shades you he opened a window she
crawled the window
[Music]
oh god please don't be there oh god [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
I don't know what to do grandmas gone
listen go back to where you like he hit
me shovel he's killed me I'm just gonna
run a little bit I'm just it's not as
fast as I can run cuz it's not very fast
but you can sprint rocky it's a Keith's
gone dead Oh run away hi
[Music]
Oh [ __ ] bed hold that one
ah no bread
don't know where to go I can't see I
can't see
rubbish turn the brightness up actually
yeah we try and then she know like he is
now but that guy's gonna see me you
could wait until he's walking back to
where he just died and then when its
back is to you grab the key and go yeah
presumably I'd unlocks that floor hatch
it was hard wait where am I okay try
turn the brightness up in the options
yeah keep going
yeah oh wow this is the same game that's
much better
I feel like that's cheating no I kind of
want to figure out this thing okay so
this is back to like what we did with
the resident once that's my bullet how
much do you want me to like help you you
want me to wait
I'm obviously I'll let you figure out
everything until wow I can actually see
this [ __ ] room now
I think if I get stuck I'll ask for your
help
I bet you one of the stupid women are
down here secure the tape that can't be
removed by a hand that a joke because I
lost my hand that's like the question
why can't you move
it's just saying it's just reminding me
that it's a garage and gun oh it's okay
got it all right so I got bullets no gun
yeah
am I making too much noise baby where is
that [ __ ] can I lean like can he see
me
I don't know is he coming yeah you might
have to trigger him [ __ ] and then when
you see him come back and wait for him
to walk get triggered oh so like when he
turns goes past that corner then you can
grab the beat like now yeah should I run
no I'm afraid it'll make too much noise
oh god go you [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] what you got it without him
noticing
is that not normal you can and I just
thought by that point he would have turn
around I'm really good at this game
floor hatch do you member to get back
there
floor hatch remember the hatch in the
floor that was locked
yeah I just wanted to try that
okay we're getting there that's right
I'm the best gamer in the work this
place is too big
you're like one side of the house right
now it's just really hard to keep track
of all these spaces jerks oh that's nice
those are important actually
oh so keep an eye out for those okay
Oh is he here I'm actually is he here
what was that did they come in here did
they come in she answer me Oh God
Oh God okay well that's not gonna save
me
what's that I mean do your thing Oh
classic herb combined items an herb
combined with some chem fluid I tell ya
just a protip go back to that menu press
r1
that's way faster so instead of having
to pick the two individual things you
just pick them a fluid and it'll take
the two things
oh cool just for future reference got it
he's yours like how to build in the
middle of a fight no it's not it like it
does it for you pretty great yeah
like once you've made one maybe it's
like it got a recipe correct
Oh Lord what is that no I want to open
it oh there we go nice okay so um the
bobblehead somewhere oh they really
stink
what do you mean I don't I just heard a
bobblehead all right should I go so
scary
[Music]
wait but I don't want to I thought they
were gonna answer the phone I don't know
where there's nice do you know what I
mean yeah okay just I give that a whirl
oh actually remember there's no locked
cabinet like right here on the other
side of the wall I do be a gun what am i
doing
with what I hate to say this but I think
you have to answer the phone really but
it's not even ringing anywhere know
where it is can I break it with this
thing can I
oh I'd lost that lockpick yeah the
burner
oh I didn't know that not the master of
lock-picking like Jill Valentine I
didn't know that well I'm actually not
sure what to do now my plan was to use
that lock book like on this I just
thought if I poked it with something
that would work out I don't really think
I thought this through where's the phone
I don't know oh it's in that room in the
laundry room yeah shut this you got to
get out of that house it might be a way
out through the main hall all right oh
and that thing on your wrist is a codex
don't lose it it's stable
a codec hell of a girl so the main
hallway is where that guy is though yeah
do you think I don't know do you think I
need anything like a handgun ammo in
case you still have four other slots if
you do find girls okay sorry five others
all right so the main the main hallway
where that guy is and he's totally gonna
see me and then one like this doesn't
seem like a good plan so save you might
not be here anymore member you heard us
what steps oh right
classic feeling Lucas
you [ __ ]
Jack and Marguerite 25th wedding
anniversary hello hey hi sorry to
intrude bobbleheads are so like they
were creepy before me a favor look down
to your left behind that wooden plank
against the wall yeah you might have to
crouch Thanks good job that's why you're
here okay
I need to find a horse body his horse
but in order to get in all right we're
getting there
slowly but surely hey there anything
else hate you because basically Oh God I
remember you please don't very long
hallway
and I can't leave boarded up classic dog
scenes oh yeah are you two or one sorry
and two it's yeah that's a Bob why
offense what's that noise
Oh God who's that open up who's that hey
over here
hi how you guys oh you're [ __ ] soon
milk or dead
no sir do you live here I mean is this
your property what me no no alright now
we got several calls about some missing
persons late
you understand I gotta get out of here
calm down you're not listening to me
there are crazy people in this house
trying to [ __ ] kill me alright let me
tell you this you don't exactly seem
like you playing with a full deck
yourself alright are you kidding me look
like I said we've had several missing
persons call and I can't rule out that
an outsider like yourself may not be
involved all right I'll tell you
whatever you is that double negative
alright now that's normally the groan
hey wait you gotta give me your gun look
officer deputy right deputy how do you
want to see my name in the obituaries
but you want to be a hero and save my
life
nice
somebody's been reading never split the
different pocket knife here go garage
now
tape tape can be cut with a knife to do
with a knife cut tape dum-dum tape tape
tape tape oh whoa wait they're always
like that yeah I'm stupid I never saw
that weird all right oh wait come on go
back can you hit that with a knife this
no the box are too
I cut my arm off [ __ ]
oh right you should never touch buttons
before thinking about it too late go
you're in it now we gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here now first you need to tell
me what you're doing out here alone in
the middle of the night me what about
you it's my job once you do your job and
tell me answer my questions you have to
believe me if I told you the trunk oh my
god
does that serve that is a shirt well
she's dead come on q-tip guns on the
ground where's yours that bike
but
God change equipped item yeah just shoot
you shoot him in the face for Maxim
stressful come this way old Birds
[ __ ] I have very few of these what he's
really bad where the hell you think
you're going it's pretty fast for an
elder I don't want to go in here maybe
you do I pushed him catch you first -
[ __ ] hold Marguerite did you net uh
gunpowder in one template I don't
understand let me :
oh my god you're too fast can I go
Emeline around watch the Peru there's no
time
crap I needed that car it's [ __ ]
insane
hila r1 check that blogger in there
or use that right now
[Applause]
and I like
there's nowhere to go combined big
bullets are one oh god shoot sorry
that was hard jeez I found a [ __ ]
thing way to play pummeling you the hood
of a whatever car that is [ __ ] like what
a psycho just gets in a car starts
cheering wait oh good I don't to do
everything over again hey we gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here now first you need
to tell me what you're doing out of your
lawn in the middle of the night so why
should I get killed it what about you oh
it's my job don't you do your job and
tell me it's my little partner you're
not gonna believe me if I told you right
all right [ __ ] you what do I do now just
hit the cart yeah all right I can't
believe the parks were there no way
change weapons you'll get the gun Yeah
right
he's gonna kill me you got 18 bullet
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
oh the cars to ope
[Applause]
my god I don't know how to do this are
you guys okay what do I do
could you jump out of there no I don't
think I'm yeah no stop shooting him
[Music]
get up no don't get in the cart oh you
got him I did for now I think is he dead
he looks dead he does look dead oh my I
don't think I've ever seen the car
before you leave the garage there was I
saw crate should I say should I he'll
wait did it open the whole line go back
to where the car is kind of there was a
crate on one of these shelves I don't
know if it oh yeah I don't know if I can
get to it
I can try are you not jump in this game
no there you go oh I didn't mean to do
that
sorry I can't blow it will be helpful if
you can reach it I have some bad news
can you not maybe the car will be moved
if you come back later but [ __ ] you
right now what
[ __ ] do I get out of here I thought I
was gonna die again the ladder right
next to them oh [ __ ] that's how you die
boy you're about to see some more
whoa unnecessary I didn't lose a bullet
though hey socks Oh what was that
hey oppressor
well great shotgun shells okay
whenever you get that
go back to Sabre in laundry room
where's moebus why do I talk about oh
you want oh yeah is a good that was a
good ending [ __ ] like blue bye
it didn't feel like it was that there's
a lot of things I want to say about this
first hour and a half but you can't ruin
anything
yeah not story-wise just like for the
rest of the game okay I do it
6:18 I think so maybe not do it you seem
very good that's weird
what time is it a new save that on case
I don't think you did oh I must have hit
no cuz I'm dumb boy that was scary yeah
so that's the end we'll be back next
week don't know when we're recording
next episode about you're back from
Australia so yeah I'm back from Down
Under
jet lag dis [ __ ] thank you guys for
watching if you guys like this stuff
don't forget to like I'm subscribe it
helps gamespot.com sweet we'll see you
next week Oh actually Han let me give
you thoughts this is your first time
playing Rosie o 7s what do you think so
far um yeah it's really good very scary
already they've done a great job like
building the tension I don't know anyone
and it's not like I should care about
myself there was no exposition that I
instinctively want to live yeah I'm kind
of like pushing my buttons with making
me go down hallways I don't want to go
down they've done it like three times
already or like there was that time
where like my girlfriend was making
those like wheezing noises but I had to
go down the hallway to see her is
intense and then I had to go down the
hallway to get that key and they're
doing a job good job at like making me
not want to go down places and then
making me go down those places that
Mysterio's great the anticipation is
building the doors are so right
didn't evil which I'm really excited
about and I love this babes they've done
that you have herbs and combining herbs
but the chem fluid you can use with
gunpowder for bullets or with herbs oh
that's good so you decide whether you
want health or bullets
it gets ya the crafting in this game
becomes three big supply management
stuff survival I'm excited it's been a
mere hour and a half and I'm really into
it I like it very much and I want to
play more sweet
well everybody thank you for visiting
whether you're new to this show or if
you've been with us since resin Evil
remake you can go back and watch all the
other ones if you want to catch up
otherwise we'll be back next week well
Resident Knievel's 7 the penultimate
game new people are not gonna get that
joke penultimate last one